what's good everyone Michael here from
game tech to show you the social space
in destiny 2 on PC be using maximum
settings and I am joined by our video
producer Emily Conte hello thank you for
being here Emily we're looking at the
social space here it's called the farm
and it looks like a farm where you can
play soccer I'm working with a core i7
CPU I don't know which one it is because
this is not my computer well I know that
we have 16 gigs of ram and a gtx 1070 so
do you just have the basic settings
right now before we start playing soccer
good thing you brought that up Emily
so yeah let's take a look at the
settings that we're actually using what
does it mean to have max settings well
kind of cheated here so I'll show you
what I'm doing so yeah we have a 1080p
monitor right here we're not doing 4k so
you have a couple presets low to highest
this is basically what the highest sets
for you except for anti-aliasing right
here MSA is being worked on currently
Bungie said not to use it because it's
still in the works so we use SMA a this
is a little cheating right here so
render resolution which is super
sampling I said it's a 133 percent which
essentially gives us 1440p since we're
going off of 1080p boosting it up 133
percent which means it's rendering 1440p
and then down scaling for us but it
looks pretty clean and what is SMA a
Steinberg and sub pixel morphological
anti-aliasing kind of a balance between
full-on anti-aliasing where it detects
the edges of all these objects and kind
of gets rid of the aliasing some of the
faster techniques that don't take as
much from your hardware
it looks nice it's not as it's not the
greatest method but it helps but I added
boost super sampling or render
resolution a little bit so clean up the
picture a little bit so we can see
things in much finer detail so here we
have a lot of geometry so we're looking
at this house you have kind of the
wooden beams got the steel beams around
there all these objects that are
supposed to be straight lines so yeah
we're working with SMA a and a little
bit of super sampling let's check it out
when we turn it
and then we'll turn it down to 100%
which means it's straight-up 1080p
rendering take a quick look at V wooden
beams along this house and kind of the
sides of that steel structure or if you
want to look at the tree trunks you'll
see some jaggies there for sure yeah oh
and look at those stair steps too so
yeah those steps right there and the
bench yeah you'll see some jaggies right
there so we get rid of that we want to
make it look sweet
it's the SMA let's boost it back to 133
percent render resolution and do you
figure out that percentage uh Nathan
specifically or do you just kind of
gauge it oh you kinda just got do some
math oh the 1080p resolution if you
boost that up it's roughly 1440 well
that's kind of how I'm calculating that
because if you boost it all the way up
to 200% doubling the pixel count both
horizontally and vertically which means
there's four times the amount of pixels
which gets you roughly what 4k would
look like they do see some screen
tearing every so often oh yeah where we
got the uncapped framerate and we're not
using B sync and we're not using a
g-sync monitor so you're gonna get some
screen tearing but it's not it's not
game breaking I'd much rather have vsync
off with an uncapped framerate notice
changing shadow effects is that
graphically demanding on your PC yes
when you look in a graphics menu you see
a lot of you know texture quality shadow
quality lighting quality like all these
simple quality terms but in terms of how
demanding something is shadow quality
tends to be the most demanding out of
all of them so it could be beneficial if
you want to turn that down a notch to
medium you probably get a couple extra
frames per second is it because it's
adding more pixels or do you know why I
could I could probably get this wrong
very easily but I believe it's that your
computer doesn't have to calculate
shadows as accurately so the shadow is
essentially rendered at a lower res mm
if your computer doesn't have to
calculate as much detail less demanding
yeah so I found a nice windmill shadow
here it looks very detailed oh look how
fine that is
beautiful that's why you'd want shadow
quality as high as possible I look like
a shadow CEO it's really nice you see
all the fine detail speaking of fine
details let's take a look at texture
take a hard look at that grass it looks
a little flat and let's bump it up it's
hard to tell which means that it's okay
if you play on lower settings what are
the primary graphic settings that you
would change if you're gonna play
campaign so if I'm playing in campaign
or if I'm playing like a PvE where I'm
not really competitive with other people
I'd like to crank everything up as much
as possible I want to have 60 frames per
second as a consistent as possible but
if it dips to like high 40s I don't
really mind so I would have
anti-aliasing ambient occlusion all
those all those things cranked up as
much as I can but if I go to a
competitive mode I would probably turn
down anti-aliasing first
just because of how demanding it can be
so I could save myself some frames per
second and make sure I stay above 60
since I'm on a 60 Hertz monitor - oh
yeah let's turn off chromatic aberration
and film grain so it's just taxing on
your system and there's no point really
it doesn't I don't think it's it doesn't
affect your system performance okay I
don't see any point using it but that's
the thing by all means do it so purely
stylistic and doesn't affect you one way
or another what really want to know what
how these things work you should check
out our video on ambient occlusion if
you're interested in anti-aliasing check
out our video on anti aliasing we have
wait we've done so many of those Emily
like yo we got the whole thing for you
yep full education yeah we hand out
college degrees and everything oh we
don't don't lie on Todd videos man so
normally when you go into the menu you
won't see 3d as an option it's
exclusively a destiny - features this is
this is the first time I've seen it as
that okay so I don't know if it's like
proprietary tech that's exclusive to
know either Nvidia or Bungie or anything
but it is the it is the first time I've
seen it as the name of the option let's
check out this ambient occlusion real
quick
[Music]
and let's bump this up to the three
besetting Oh see if you look under that
box right here this box mm-hmm
Oh got a little bit more detail around
the edges as if it's some man oh thanks
yeah you'll get a little bit more detail
as like you'll get darker areas where
light shouldn't be so it'll look more
realistic sometimes that stuff's not
tied to the shadow setting and then with
mech settings you haven't really seen a
big performance issue right you only saw
maybe the difference of a couple frames
per second yeah the social space is a
lot bigger it's a lot more expansive we
might get frame dips again I'm using
super sampling SMA but that's to be
expected is that kind of one of the
advantages of this game though is that
you can pretty much play with everything
on high and performance this look
everything will be on point
yeah it's I think it's definitely an
advantage for this particular game in
the PC gaming space I know Metro last
light still gives systems a lot of
problems brings them down to their knees
so it's still one of those marquee
benchmark games destiny - I don't think
will be even though it looks great this
is a game where you can safely crank
things up as high as you can if you have
a good system and not have to worry
about frame drops but again this is a
beta and we'll see improvements or when
the game is released but we'll also see
how demanding it will get in really
crazy strikes when you're fighting a lot
of enemies and you have whole party so
we'll see with that I can't come to a
conclusion about that now obviously
because we only have one strike and it
runs really well though so that's an
indicator should be pumped up yeah this
cream looks amazing well thank you so
much for explaining all those settings I
feel like I'm ready to jump into this
beta
Oh got a texture quality huh nice if you
want to see more from gamespot please
subscribe to our channel it's so dope we
have a lot of great content you know a
lot of the things I explained here have
been explained in previous videos please
check those out on our channel thanks
for watching see you next time